separately police here in New York are
increasing their presence in
neighborhoods with large Jewish
populations following a series of
anti-semitic attacks it comes as Jewish
people celebrated Hanukkah and as civil
rights groups are noting an uptick in
hate crimes across the country Don
Dahler reports on December 24th a 56
year old Jewish man in Brooklyn was
approached by a group of men one of whom
punched him in the back of the head that
same day a 25 year old man was attacked
in the same area he told police a group
of men cursed at him saying effing Jew
before throwing a liquid on him those
are just two of at least eight Bias
attacks this week in New York including
a man struck in Manhattan and a mother
in Brooklyn hit in the head while
walking with her three-year-old son it's
scary to know that people are being
attacked simply because they're Jewish
rabbi Jonathan leaner lives in Brooklyn
with his wife and two young children as
a rabbi for a whole congregation making
sure all of those people are safe is
part of my responsibility as well which
is stressful considering the uptick in
the violence
hate crimes are on the rise nationally
particularly against Jews assault on
them are up a hundred and five percent
the worst of which was the Tree of Life
Massacre in Pittsburgh in 2018 that took
the lives of 11 people earlier this
month there was a deadly attack in
Jersey City on a kosher grocery store in
the past year a dozen white supremacists
have been arrested for plots or attacks
against Jews Evan Bernstein is regional
director of the anti-defamation league
why are these hate crimes on the rise
we've seen a lot of gentrification
issues housing issues cultural strife
that takes place lack of communication
but a lot of that has been there for a
lot of years but also has been there
anti-semitism that's been part of our
culture for generations and now we've
seen kind of the uncapping of that over
the last four years
the first detectives we happened here on
New York's Upper East Side a man was
punched and kicked after a suspect
allegedly made an anti-semitic remark
now in light of these attacks the NYPD
has beefed up patrols in Jewish
neighborhoods and New York's governor
has
erected a hate crimes task force to look
into them for CBS this morning Saturday
Don Dahler New York
you